ça c'est une excellente nouvelle si vous
cherchez des infos sur les derniers
samsung galaxy s 21 qui viennent tout
juste d'être annoncé
eh bien vous êtes au bon endroit j'ai eu
la chance de les voir il ya quelques
jours sous embargo de les prendre en
main de les découvrir et tester d'avoir
toutes les infos d'être bien briefé par
les équipes de samsung merci à samsung
je vais donc vous dévoiler aujourd'hui
c'est trois modèles vous saurez tout de
tout de tout de tout et ça c'est génial
en plus de ça bonus et ça c'est une
excellente nouvelle je relance enfin le
podcast fréquents heureux vous avez tous
les liens dans la description et
justement aujourd'hui on est une
interview aujourd'hui de william george
qui est chef produit chez samsung qui
vous dit tout sur ce nouveau samsung
galaxy s 21
on est parti on en parle de ses nouveaux
smartphones directement dans le podcast
ça va écoute ça très bien
ouais ouais très bien très bien je suis
heureux d'accueillir dans le podcast ben
moi aussi je suis ravi de parler de
pâques avec toi de ses sorties prenant
donc allé retrouver le podcast vous avez
liens dans la description comme ça vous
ne saurez plus on dira plus de choses on
va les tailles et plein de points et ça
va être super cool on va rentrer dans le
détail essayer tout comprendre le
podcast est vraiment complémentaire de
cette vidéo ici je vous parle des specs
je vous explique le produit ce que vous
allez pouvoir en faire et dans le
podcast on rentre dans les détails et
vous allez apprendre des choses qui sont
super intéressant et super surprenante
une fois de plus vous avez le lien en
bas dans la description
je ne sais pas si vous eûtes coutumier
et si vous connaissez très bien légal
samsung on va résumer tout ça
vous avez déjà la gamme s la gamme drop
on parle aujourd'hui qui est axé sur la
photo et la vidéo vous avez ensuite la
gamme note qui est présenté au mois de
juillet au mois d'août est une gamme
axée sur la productivité avec le fameux
espn le stylet pour trouver ensuite la
gamme à qui l'entrée et milieu de gamme
et enfin la gamme z qui est basée sur
l'innovation notamment sur le samsung
galaxy z paul ii 2 qui est le pliage
vous avez le z flip et puis tous les
modèles qui vont arriver en 2021 et dans
les années à venir voilà ces quatre
grandes gammes vous permet de resituer
les modèles on va donc se concentrer
aujourd'hui sur les nouveaux samsung
galaxy s 21 que sont le s 21 s 21 de
plus et le s 21
ultra on a vu arriver l'année dernière
en 2020 pour la première fois un modèle
ultra samsung
num signe et persiste avec un samsung
galaxy s 21 ultra alors vous allez voir
il ya vraiment fait deux grands produits
à comprendre là dessus s-21 s-21 plus
vont plutôt fonctionné ensemble avec
quelques petites différences notamment
au niveau de la taille de l'écran
notamment au niveau du dos mais
globalement c'est plus ou moins le même
produit avec une évolution
le samsung galaxy s 21 ultra est
vraiment à part on est dans l'excellence
on est dans ce que samsung sait faire
mieux aujourd'hui à un instant t
début 2000 21 et d'ailleurs c'est super
intéressant de voir que ils font 7 qui
note beaucoup plus tôt l'année dernière
j'étais parti avec lui à san francisco
on était au mois de février
plus tôt dans la deuxième partie de
février pour un découvert les samsung
galaxy s 20 cette année je pense que le
christ de covina chamboulé pas mal
d'agenda on arrive donc tout début
d'année pendant le ces est ce pour vous
présenter leur nouveau flagship le
premier point qui va être le plus
intéressant ce avec la partie design je
sais pas si vous avez vu des fuites sur
internet qui vous montrer un tout
nouveau design samsung essayer un petit
peu de se réinventer et de faire une
nouvelle proposition notamment au niveau
de l'arrière au niveau du blog photos
qu'on va retrouver avec une finition
métal un bloc déportée sur la gauche et
avec une tranche qui est en aluminium et
surtout une plus intéressant ce sont les
premiers samsung galaxy s avec un dos
matt
ici pas de traces de doigts alors au
niveau du dos on a aussi une différence
cette fois-ci avec le samsung galaxy s
21 ans côté et les s-21 puce s-21 ultra
de l'autre côté
le samsung galaxy s 21 un dos en
plastique c'est du polycarbonate tandis
que sur les s-21 plus et s-21 ultra vous
avez un dos en vert mat à l'oeil nu
la différence est pas vraiment visible
on sent plutôt au toucher ça c'est un
truc intéressant parce que l'année
dernière j'allais assez critiqué le
samsung galaxy note vin auquel je
reprochais réellement d'avoir ce d'eau
en plastique sur une gamme note
on pourrait faire le même reproche sur
une gamme galaxy s j'ai juste une prise
en main de produits une découverte je
vous en reparlerai plus longuement dans
le test vous invite donc dès maintenant
à venir vous abonner si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas
comme ça je donnerai mon retour complet
sur ce produit d'ici quelques jours ce
qui est bien avec ce dôme at si vous
n'allez plus avoir de traces de doigts
il ya un côté moins salissant plus
premium bien jouer samsung on va voir
aussi une déclinaison de plusieurs
couleurs vous y retrouver le samsung
galaxy s 21
angry en blanc
violet mais également rose le s-21 plus
en noix en argent et en violet tandis
que le samsung galaxy s 21 ultra sera
disponible uniquement en noir et en
argent puisque ici vous avez smartphone
premium il faut penser à venir les
protéger et justement pour ce faire j'ai
des productions mon partenaire rhino
chine ici j'ai deux coques sont les soli
de suite pour les samsung galaxy s 21
vous avez une grande gamme chez
rhinochill pour les samsung galaxy s 21
s-21 plus est ce vote a utre à est pour
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup smartphone
vous avez bien évidemment des solitudes
qui sont des coqs qui vont venir
complètement protégé votre smartphone et
vous avez des solitudes qui sont
décorées à des couleurs hyper sympa
notamment couleurs de basket ici avec
les chicago bulls également aux couleurs
de force night hunter enter sans oublier
des crashs garde qui vont venir entourer
votre smartphone et qu'ils laisseront la
face visible mais également les modèles
x sur lesquels et pouvoir ajouter des
skins complètement personnalisée
notamment league of legends
il y en a plein pour tous les goûts très
sympa mais ça ne s'arrête pas là puisque
vous allez aussi des protections d'écran
oui parce que ces écrans faut quand même
venir les protéger autant vous dire que
vous avez beaucoup de soin à cherry nos
chiffres ça c'est super vous avez un
code provende réduction de 5% dans la
description
profitez-en quand il faut vraiment venir
protéger votre nouveau smartphone comme
je le disais la gamme sc la gamme photos
vidéos ou non tout est rentré dans les
specs photos vidéos pour essayer de voir
ce que samsung nous a proposé de nouveau
en 2021
soyons clairs on va retrouver la même
configuration qu'on avait sur les
samsung galaxy s 20 la différence et si
c'est que les capteurs vont être de
nouvelle génération ils permettront de
capter plus de lumière et d'avoir un
meilleur rendu global
une fois de plus ça on pourra vraiment
le voir lors des phases de test qui
arriveront d'ici quelques jours on aura
donc une meilleure profondeur des
couleurs moins de bruit numérique
notamment sur la photo de nuit sur tout
ce qui nous intéressait c le zoom sur le
samsung galaxy s 21 ultra on a pas moins
de deux téléobjectifs 2t l'objectif pour
aller chercher très loin
souvenez-vous l'année dernière soit
samsung galaxy s 20 ultra on avait déjà
ce zoom périscopique ce qu'ils appellent
le space zoom jusqu'à fois sans c'était
assez dingue
et c'est vrai quand on arrivait aux
poissons on avait en tout cas un petit
peu what the fuck mais en terme de
qualité ce n'était pas non plus
absolument incroyable sur l'ultra et
uniquement sur l'ultra vous avez s'est
dotée l'objectif sur le premier vous
allez voir un zoom optique x 3 et son
deuxième but est d'avoir un zoom optique
x 10 il faut vraiment l'imaginé
travaillant comme une continuité
vous allez pouvoir zoomer fois de sueur
rent angles or si vous avez le zoom
optique il va prendre le relais à partir
de foix iii et jusqu'à x 10 et à partir
de x 10 jusqu'à fois sans surprise zone
eh bien ce sera le deuxième téléobjectif
qui va prendre le relais sur les
différents paliers que ce soit du x 32 x
20 et compagnie la nouveauté c'est comme
vous avez de nouveaux capteurs vous
allez avoir une meilleure définition
meilleur captation de la lumière la
technologie dual pixels qui veut servir
notamment pour l'autofocus est sûre
modèle ultra vous avez notamment un
laser qui servira pour l'autofocus en
conditions de faible luminosité sur ce
space zoom vous avez également de
l'intelligence artificielle qui vous
offrira une meilleure netteté vous avez
également une nouveauté ça s'appelle le
zoom
loc lorsque vous menez zoomer loin dans
l'image vous avez un petit aperçu qui
s'ouvre pour savoir toujours ou est-ce
que vous en êtes ça c'est très pratique
très malin et on l'avait déjà l'année
dernière vous appuyez dessus ça va figer
l'image voulait pouvoir prendre une
photo les photos de nuit sont également
améliorées mais son grade et si quelques
jours tandis que sont les directions
s-21 et s-21 plus vous avez un zoom
optique x 3 et 1 au numérique x 30
voilà pour la partie photo maintenant on
va s'intéresser à la partie vidéo
quelles que soient les objectifs de
votre smartphone vous pouvez filmer
jusqu en 4k à 60 images par secondes et
vous pouvez même filmé jusqu'en 8 cas à
24 images par seconde ça on l'avait déjà
l'année dernière mais là où il ya une
nouveauté c'est que vous avez le vidéo
snap pouvait extraire une photo depuis
votre vidéo en 8k à 24 images par
seconde si par exemple vous filmer une
scène dans huit catégories tiens ça
c'était super bien je voudrais récupérer
pour faire une miniature par exemple ou
alors un super moment vous voulez
récupérer une image tac vous faites le
vidéo snap et vous récupérez une super
image
une nouveauté qui est assez rigolote
c'est le mode réalisateur comme si vous
étiez un réalisateur cinéma vous
explique vous allez voir par exemple une
vidéo depuis votre capteur grand-angle
et en bas vous allez voir les autres
capteurs vous allez voir le téléobjectif
vous allez voir l'ultra grand angle et
vous allez également voir votre caméra
de selphy l'enregistrement vous allez
pouvoir en faire c'est ce qu'on appelle
le picture in picture une image dans une
autre image ça peut être intéressant
pour certains modes de prise de vue mais
tant soit peu regretté l'astuce et que
vous ne pouvez pas enregistré
indépendamment chaque vidéo pour pouvoir
ensuite les exporter et les traitaient
comme vous le voulez non vous avez un
seul fichier vidéo qui extraient fameux
picture in picture ça peut être
intéressant à voir les usa d'ailleurs
dit mme en vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire le mode d'action cam
passe de 30 images par seconde à 60
images par seconde pour des ralentis
beaucoup plus fluide et le mode single
take évolué avec le mode single take 2.0
qui vous permettra de faire beaucoup
plus de choses parce que vous avez
dernier
processeur qui est plus puissant donc
plus de capacités de calcul
souvenez-vous l'année dernière le mode
single take vous y ait une petite vidéo
de quelques secondes
ça vous permettez d'extraire notamment
des photos des vidéos des ralentis
différentes couleurs du noir et blanc
tout ça avec une seule prise de vue
c'est assez bluffant
j'ai hâte de pouvoir tester le single
take 2.0 pour vraiment pouvoir vous
donner mon retour puisque ce mode single
take se fait parce que déjà vous avez un
processeur qui est plus performant et
bien on a un tout nouveau processeur qui
vient d'être présentée par samsung c'est
l'exynos 2107 un processeur qui est
gravée en 50 nanomètres
une fois de plus je ne le connais pas
encore donc on en reparlera dans
quelques jours le temps de faire le test
autre point fort de samsung ce sont les
écrans sont les dalles sur toujours des
dalles qui sont hyper bien calibré hyper
bien maîtrisée samsung aujourd'hui vous
le connaissez notamment au travers des
produits qu'il fabrique mais samsung
également fabricant d'écrans pour plein
d'autres marques vous pouvez retrouver
sur marché autant vous dire que quand il
s'agit d'avoir des écrans pour leur
propre smartphone ils ont des écrans de
superbe qualité avec notamment là une
nouvelle dalle c'est la dynamique amoled
2 x c'est une nouvelle version la
dynamique amoled renom qui s'y retrouver
trois tailles d'écran 6,2 pouces pour le
samsung galaxy s 21 6,7 pouces pour le
samsung galaxy s 21 plus très grand et
6,8 pouces pour le samsung galaxy s 21
ultra ultra forcément le plus gros la
plus grosse dalle vous en douterez tous
les trois sont équipés de la même
technologie de dalle avec du 120 hertz
adaptatif alors qu'est ce que le 120
hertz adaptatif et bien votre écran au
repos pas précisément maximale de son
aise lorsque des applications
nécessiteront du sang vers si par
exemple vous êtes en train de regarder
je sais pas moi une photo où vous
naviguez sur le smartphone vous avez pas
forcément devant 200 hertz et bien ce
moment-là il passera soit 90 hertz soit
en 60 hertz
je crois que vous passez de 48 heures
jusqu'à 120 hertz sur le samsung galaxy
s 21 ans et s-21 plus et de aux herses
jusqu'à 120 hertz soit 500 galaxy s 21
ultra justement on en parle dans ce
podcast on vous explique tout une fois
de plus le lien dans la description sur
le s 21 l'es21 plus vous avez une
résolution full hd plus tandis que sur
les 21 ultra vous avez deux résolutions
en w qhd vous pouvez ont plus à voir en
s'envoyant des dates sont certifiés
lutter contre la lumière bleue et il ya
un autre point qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est que le samsung galaxy
s 21 ultra est compatible avec le s pen
le s pen c'est le style et 202 soupe si
par exemple vous avez une tablette de
samsung comme une tabelle si par exemple
vous avez votre stylet vous
pour l'utiliser sur le modèle ultra et
sur l'ultra uniquement ça permettra
d'aller plus loin sur de la productivité
pour venir dessiner pour tout ce que
vous voulez la question à se poser c'est
est-ce que le fait d'abord un stylet sur
le modèle ultra ne va pas venir un peu
éclipsé la gamme galaxy note ça on
dirait pour une fois de plus dans le
podcast jamais le lien dans la
description
la grosse différence vous y retrouver
notamment ici c'est que vaut le stylet
vous n'avez pas pouvoir leur charge et
dont toutes les fonctions bluetooth que
vous avez notamment les apps gesture et
si vous ne les aurais pas vous aurez sur
la gamme notes et pas sur la gamme s
en tout cas en 2021 autre nouveauté le
capteur d'empreintes digitales et 70%
plus large à la différence de dernière
on avait des smartphones 4g et 5g si
tous les smartphones sont 5 g et
nouveauté qui est assez intéressante et
samsung cette année ils ont fait
disparaître le port de cartes microsd
vous n'avez donc pas la possibilité d
temps le stockage de votre smartphone
vous avez donc plusieurs configurations
en termes de stockage mais ça ne vous à
part dans quelques instants
soit je donne les configurations et les
tarifs autre nouveauté intéressante el
fassi dans la boîte vous n'avez plus de
blocs de charge la dernière apple a
commencé à ses iphone 12 plus de blocs
de charge intégrée samsung fait la même
chose c'est pour une démarche éco
responsable c'est très bien pour la
planète ça peut faire râler les
consommateurs qui n'ont pas de bloc de
chars et qui vont devoir l'acheter en
plus tout en sachant qu'ici vous avez
une recharge maximale de 25 watts
on peut se dire que par rapport à
certains concurrents qui ont des blocs
de charge de 65 watts voire même plus on
peut se dire que c'est un peu lent mais
en réalité une charge trop rapide
d'avenir limiter la durée de vie de
votre batterie dans le temps mieux vaut
privilégier des charges un peu plus
lente 25 watts et quand même malgré tout
rapide donc ici ça me va parfaitement
par contre dans votre boîte rassurez
vous avez quand même un câble usb c'est
usb c'est donc si vous avez un
ordinateur en usb c'est vous pouvez
recharger dessus ça sera pratique et
vous retrouvez également de la charge
sans fil vos smartphones tournent sur la
nouvelle version de when you lie c'est
au moins deux à trois points 11 ans avec
quelques nouvelles fonctionnalités mais
ça on en parlera également un peu plus
tard et en termes de configuration de
stockage sur les samsung galaxy s 21 et
s-21 plus vous avez le choix entre 128
ou 256 go de stockage tandis que sur le
modèle ultra vous avez soit 128 soit 256
soit 512 512 c'est un monstre
quand même il faut le dire ces
smartphones coûte quand même j'ai les
tarifs et sillage vous dit tout le s 21
en version 128 go de stockage commence à
859 euros et en version 256 go de
stockage 909 euros le samsung galaxy s
plus coûte 1000 59 euros en 128 go de
stockage et en 256 milles 109 euros
tandis que le samsung galaxy s 21 ultra
en 128 giga de stockage coûte 1200 59
euros 250 6309 euros et 512000 409 euros
on va donc partir de 859 euros jusqu'à
1400 9 euros sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais ce qui est très
intéressant et c'est très rare du coup
je lui précise les tarifs baissent les
tarifs augmentent toujours de partout la
banque où les tarifs baissent
si vous prenez un samsung galaxy s 21 on
s'endette giga de stockage le tarif va
être plus bas que le samsung galaxy ace
vannes l'année dernière par la même
configuration
là où d'autres constructeurs vont garder
les mêmes tarifs en retirant des blocs
de charge
ici on va voir un smartphone nouvelle
génération moins cher sa part thierry je
trouve vraiment intéressant et très
malin de la part de samsung
donc ça gros pouce bleu un smartphone
vous pouvez précommander dès aujourd'hui
mais qui sera disponible à partir du 29
janvier prochain magasin et s'il vous
intéresse je vous aime tous les liens en
bas dans la description du coup cette
année au catalogue dans la gamme galaxy
s
on va retrouver les s 21 est ce matin
plus les intérêts ultra mais également
les s20 ffe les modèles de l'année
dernière s 20s ventes plus élevées
ultras ne sont plus au catalogue
vous pourrez toujours y retrouve être
dans le commerce chez différents
retailer mai sur le site de samsung
termine à dos samsung nous parle
également de connectivité avec votre
smartphone vous allez pouvoir notamment
redémarrer votre voiture quand vous
arrivez ouvrir la porte de votre garage
à distance grâce à un écosystème
connectés ça on n'en parlera plus tard
bien évidemment c'est en tout cas très
intéressant tous ses smartphones senti
fier ip68 résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière et vous avez aussi une petite
différence qui est vraiment intéressante
au niveau du samsung galaxy s 21
ultra vous avez les technologies wifi 6e
les autres sont wifi 6 celui-là profit
d'une technologie un peu plus avancé une
fois de plus on a beaucoup plus loin
dans les explications de podcasts la vie
donc à venir le découvrir en cliquant
sur le lien en bas dans la description
vous médias maintenant vous ce que vous
en pensez comment vous les trouvez ces
nouveaux samsung galaxy s 21
bien intéressant pas bien marquer moi
tout ça en bas est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter vous début 2021 pour
changer votre smartphone et si oui quel
smartphone vous avez actuellement marqué
moi tout ça en bas en commentaire quant
à lui se retrouve très vite pour parler
des samsung galaxy s 21 bien évidemment
et pour parler aussi de plein d'autres
choses peu d'actu parce qu'en ce moment
ça ne s'arrête pas c'est très cool des
bisous de l'amour et à très vite vous
embrasse ciao pour les soins de vous